willkommen zur aktuellen sind so über
philosophische evolutionstheorie in
heute ist soll es um der vision und
harter schopenhauer gehen der wie jung
wird leider viel zu wenig an deutschen
universitäten gelehrt das mag damit
zusammenhängt dass er in der kritik von
immanuel kant stand der seine
philosophie in abgrenzung von chrome
entwickelt hatte und ihm in mancher
hinsicht stahl kritisiert hat und wie
ich finde nicht immer zu recht auch wenn
er ihm viele dinge auch zugestanden hat
mir unter anderem dass er ihn aus seinem
dogmatischen schlummert erweckt habe
aber trotzdem kommt jung wie man ein
bisschen zu kurz er gilt immer noch so
als vorläufer erkannt der ihn eigentlich
erfunden habe und deswegen wollen wir
diesen seminaren dieser sitzung speziell
etwas mehr aufmerksamkeit seiner theorie
zukommen lassen und insbesondere seine
theorie der emotionen die fragen der
heutigen sitzung lauten in welchem
verhältnis stehen nach jugend- und schob
nach aber mitleid und ferne enthält das
mitleid nach jung und schaut man meine
gefühle des urteils und motivationstipps
wohnen ich darf noch mal daran erinnern
dass wir den vergangenen sitzungen ganz
ausführlich diese drei dimensionen
verhandelt haben ich flinke oben rechts
das video der letzten sitzung und weiter
frage wäre dann kann das mitleid nach
jugendgruppen aber als emotion
verstanden werden kann nicht einmal die
frage was ist eine emotion ist natürlich
immer davon ab was man darunter versteht
würde zeigen was wir gemeinhin wir alle
im seminar darunter verstehen und zwar
in abgrenzung von verwandten phänomen
wie effekten stimmungen und gefühle
werden gleich sehen da ist der video
hier abgebildet ist inbegriff des
effektes verwendet in der übersetzung
der deutschen eher nicht so ganz ohne
emotionen passt wie wir sie jetzt
besprochen haben und wir wollen einfach
mal schauen wie wir das genauso
können habe ich da noch ein paar daten
zu seinem leben und zu seiner person
er war ein schottischer er ist aufklärer
seiner auffassung nach gelangte zu
wissen nicht durch rationale einsicht
wie zum beispiel bei descartes sollen
dann durch systematische erfahrungen
also wir müssen in uns hinein schauen
und schauen was da vorgeht sind es
eindrücken wie wir sie weiter hinter
gittern können und dann wissen wir etwas
und genau so ist es auch mit den
emotionen und im speziellen mit dem
mitleid die vernunft ist nach jo nicht
das höchste sehen vermögen will vernunft
zum beispiel nach kant sondern die
vernunft ist nur eins live auf die
passions- und jetzt haben wir die
überleitung tasche wird im deutschen
wiedergegeben mit effekt also die
übersetzer des trägers der menschlichen
natur verdächtigen aus dem wir heute
etwas lesen werden die übersetzten
passion mit effekt ob das die richtige
besetzung ist das muss man mal schauen
jedenfalls wollen manchmal festhalten
die vernunft ist nur ein sklave der
affekte nach deutsche übersetzung das
ist merkwürdig wenn andere denker wie
zum beispiel markant genau das gegenteil
hauptzutaten der nächsten sitzung
komplett darauf näher zu sprechen
die manuell kann zeigt die vernunft
herrscht über die szene über die effekte
sie musik beherrschen unmoralisches sein
und sie unterliegt ihr nicht hier ist
der video behauptet hatte so das ist
jetzt der traktat über die menschennatur
1939 40 und das ist ein jugendwerk wenn
sie sehen eher 17 11 geboren da war der
gute mann 28 29 alt er ist also ziemlich
aber nichtsdestotrotz ein sehr
anregendes wird mit vielen thesen die
weit über seinen tod hinaus gewirkt
haben und nachwirken
so ist das in touristische hauptwerk
nicht nur von ihm sind auch in der
geschichte der philosophie erste
wirklich große touristische
der ist aus zwei teilen besteht
theoretischer teil ist der erste der
zweite tanken ihr praktischer teil
und außerdem ist auch der text den wir
heute lesen über die emotion bzw die
effekte wie ich schon sagte vorsicht bei
der übersetzung jungs passions werden im
deutschen das jetzt mit effekte jetzt
müssen wir genauer schauen ob das
wirklich zutrifft dann kommt vom
griechischen passion lateinisch kennen
sie die passion pension erleiden
leidenschaft aber auch erregung habe ich
auch gefunden den wörtern ruf wenn man
unter passion nach schon und erregungen
treffs glaube ich schon ihre erregung
dann da wird etwas bezeichnet was in uns
auch entsteht und nicht nur so etwas
äußerliches hat wie zum beispiel jetzt
ein gefühl das gefühl des hungers ist
hier keine regung
und ich glaube regungen trifft ziemlich
gut und mein effekt hat was von der
regierung aber ich glaube er geht nicht
ganz da hinlaufen das wollte das war
heute diskutieren also effekt und
leidenschaft dass wir nämlich auch über
sie zu fangen
passion leidenschaft die sieht auf jeden
fall nicht bedeutungs gleichen
leidenschaft scheint mir noch viel wert
sein
hingerissen muss man spricht zwar von
einem verbrechen aus leidenschaft haben
ich glaube effekt ist noch ein bisschen
als andere server können wir auch noch
mal diskutieren
jedenfalls sollte es im zentrum stehen
und zuletzt noch die frage warum spricht
nicht von effekt oder in motion was ist
ja im englischen gibt sondern von
passion
das müssen wir heute diskutieren wenn
wir uns jetzt gleich dem tal zu senken
und effizienter zentrale zitat betracht
aus diesem werk und möchte jetzt mal
vorlesen und zugleich auch bisschen
behandeln also ich jung sagt ganz am
anfang das war jetzt nicht auf den text
den sie von ihm bekommen haben das ist
die einladung da sagt der alle
positionen rezessionen sind im weitesten
sinne wahrnehmungen die sich im geiste
finden können eindrücke und
vorstellungen eingeteilt werden
eindrücke muss man dazusagen sind für
die unmittelbare starkes ins
empfindungen und vorstellungen sind nur
die schwachen abbildete eindruck also
die haben schon so eine art verarbeitung
erfahren
zu der anfang reflexion die eindrücke
lassen sich wiederum eine primäre und
sekundäre eindrücke unterteilen
diese einteilung deckt sich mit
derjenigen gerne ich mich früher beginnt
als ich eindrücke der sinneswahrnehmung
eindrücke selbst man im schnitt
ok also es gibt eindrücke die können wir
als primäre und sekundäre eindrücke
fassen und die sind analog zur
sinneswahrnehmung der direkten
wahrnehmung und der selbstfahrende ok
jetzt ist die frage wozu gehören jetzt
die passion sind das primäre oder
sekundäre eindruck
soviel kann man schon jetzt sagen ist in
die zu kontrollieren weil primäre
eindrücke oder eine zinswende und
zeitzeugen gegen der seele entstehen
oder dass gleichartige platz bezwungen
vorausgegangen sind das sind also
ursprung
die eindrücke sie entstehen aus der
körper beschaffenheit in lebensgeist
oder aus der einwirkung von objekten auf
die äußeren organe also hier wäre zb
hoher sowas nenne oder schmerz das wäre
so eine primäre sensation oder eine
sensation eindruck sekundäre eintritt
oder 100 selbstwahrnehmung und zeugen
die aus irgendeinem primären ein
professor gehen entweder ohne mittelbar
oder durch die vermittlung der
vorstellung der dhc containern ein
drittel haben eine vermittelte rolle und
sie können auch mit reflektoren hergehen
durch die vorstellung
zu ersteren gehören alle sinne drücke
eindrücke und alle körperlichen
schmerzen lustgefühle also zu den
anderen eindrücken zu zweiten die
effekte und alle ihren ähnlichen
gefühlsregungen als sekundäre eindrücke
sind effekte da sehen ist die quelle der
effekte und speziell auf das mitleid
das ist also das ganz wichtig
irgendwelche produktionen des leute
richtet einen müssen im geiste zuerst da
sein da diese eindrücke den
entsprechenden vorstellung von angehen
zu müssen gewisse eindruck zuerst da
sein dh ohne ihnen vorangehende
perzeption in der seele auftauchen da
diese von natürlichen und physikalischen
ursachen abhängen würde mich ihre
untersuchungen zu weit von meinem gegen
wirtin thema apfel hinein in die
anatomie der naturwissenschaft aus
diesem grunde werde ich hier auf jene
anderen eindrücke beschränken die
sekundäre eindrücke oder eindrücke der
selbst wahrnehmen genannt hatten
sekundäre darum weil sie entweder
auszuprobieren einfügen oder aus deren
frischen entstehen also ich möchte jetzt
nicht die premieren eindrücke behandelt
zb koma und so weiter das wort weil die
von physikalischen ursachen abhängig
ganz klar unsere biologische organismus
was dagegen wenn sich geht das hat mit
dem hunger direkt zu tun
diese eindrücke gegen er sich jetzt
widmet dieses sekundieren eindrücklich
die sind ihr etwas unseren geist treffen
also die nicht nur organischen strengen
sind jetzt sind sondern die etwas mit
unserer vernunft unserer reflexion zur
fusion zu tun haben okay sie entstehen
aus zehn premieren und aus der
vorstellung sind irgendwie abgeleitet
und insofern auch komplexer höhere stufe
könnte man auch seinen körperlichen
schmerz und lust gefühle sind die quelle
vieler effekt zu wollen wenn sie
empfunden als auch wenn sie nun
vorgestellten werden aber sie selbst
entstehen ursprünglichen ziele oder wenn
man lieber wie im körper unabhängig von
einer überragenden vorstellung überhaupt
einer vorhergehenden position bezogen
heißt wie gesagt nur fahren im weitesten
sinn ein gichtanfall nicht an langenei
perfekt dafür wie kummer hoffnung
vorliegt aber er selbst ist nicht etwa
die unmittelbaren oder einer
gemütsbewegung oder einer vorstellen
also hier sieht man das jetzt sehr schön
ein gichtanfall ist eine premiere
perzeption ein primäre eindruck der hat
jetzt zur folge und zwar durch reflexion
darauf durch reaktion darauf effekt wie
kummer aufruf uns ganz klar wenn ich
jetzt große schmerzen haben dann kann
ich darauf reflektieren und das kann mir
dann zum sekundären eindruck eines
eindruck führen oder zur sekretärin
passion wie kummer weil ich eben da ist
befürchtet eine hoffnung wenn ich mir
zum beispiel sagen hoffentlich geht der
weg ist immer der reaktion auf diese
trainieren vorkommnisse aber er selbst
eben nicht die unmittelbar von der einer
demütigung befürchten die eindrücke der
selbstwahrnehmung also die sekundären
jetzt können wiederum in zwei gattung
eingeteilt wird nämlich in ruhiger und
perfekt und heftige tawfik zur ersten
gattung gehört dass die vergangenheit
und hässlichkeit angesichts einer
handlung einer künstlerischen
komposition oder äußerer ab objekte zur
zweiten garde gehören gehören die
effekte der liebe und des hasses des
grabes oder freude des stolzes und der
niedergedrückt habe okay das haben wir
als ruhige und heftige eindrücke der
sinneswahrnehmung oder ruhig und heftige
effekte ja gefühl der hässlichkeit okay
kann jetzt mal überlegen was das ist es
sagt jedenfalls effekt der liebe und das
heißt sie ist natürlich ein bisschen
intensiver man könnte jetzt sagen
das erste was eher die ruhigen eindruck
dass jetzt von den mund nimmt könnte man
als stimmungen auffassen und die zweite
neben er als effekt oder als emotion so
wie wir das jetzt unternommen haben
diese einteilung ist bei den fans hat
jung und zwar völlig zu recht von
genauigkeit denn wie wir selbst auch
schon vergangenen sitzung gesehen hatten
ist es ganz schwierig emotionen von
gefühlen und stimmungen von effekt und
jetzt haben wir auch die personen zu
unterscheiden
das entzücken dann posieren musik reicht
auf die größte höhe wäre jene anderem
eintritt bieten spezielle effekte
gelernt werden seiner sanften
gefühlsregung abgespeckt sein können
dass sie gewissermaßen unbemerkt werden
aber im allgemeinen sind die effekte
heftiger als die gefühls region wieder
schönheit und hässlichkeit geweckt
werden
deshalb pflegt man beide eindrücken zu
schalten
da das reich des menschlichen geistes
ein zu weites inhalt nicht so viel
gestalten ist werde ich mir und das
folgende größere ordnung zu bringen
diese landläufig und einleuchtend
entscheidung anhalten
ok also er sagt ganz ganz ehrlich es ist
ganz schwierig die genau unterscheidet
und jetzt wollen wir mal genauer aus
mitleid eingehen blicken wir die effekt
den ganzen saal die passions ergibt sich
eine einteilung derselben indirekten und
direkten und indirekten effekten
verstehe ich solche die unmittelbar aus
einem gut oder übel aus schmerz oder
lust entspringen unter indirekten
effekten da eben verstehe ich solchen
die auf denselben kultur haben und bei
denen aber noch andere momente dieser
unterschiede seien unterschied kann ich
im augenblick nicht weiter rechtfertigen
verständlich machen ich kann nur ganz
allgemein bemerken dass ich unter den
internetauftritt kleinen ehrgeiz
eitelkeit liebe neid mit leiter hans
kohler
und der ist ihm ableitbare begreifen
konnte den direkten effekten steht er
begehren abschalt schmerz freude offen
für verzweiflung und die beruhigende
gewissheit
ok also eine seen der region hat eine
ganz andere unterscheidung direkt
indirekt und er fordert das mitleid bei
den indirekten effekten in details also
dass sie sich durch reaktion auf etwas
geeignet die nicht unmittelbar sind wir
wollen jetzt genauer schauen wie das zu
verstehen
das verlangen nach dem glück oder
unglück andere je nachdem wie ihr liebe
oder hass wissen finden ist zwar
billiger und ursprünglich unsere natur
eingepflanzt instinkt aber machen die
erfahrung dass dasselbe unter manche
umständen der natur künstlich
nacherzählt und euch neben hervorgerufen
werden kann
das mitleid ist ein bedauern die
schadenfreude ist freude über das
unglück an ohne dass bereitschaft oder
feindschaft bei diesem bedauern oder bei
dieser vorne mitspielen ok also er
definiert jetzt das mitleid und das war
der text sie mich ihnen geschickt hatte
als das als etwas was mit dem glück und
unglück anderer menschen zu tun hat also
darauf reagiert bedauern nehme ich ein
bedauern als reaktion auf das unglück
anderer menschen
wir bedauern auf fremde und zu richten
wir uns ganz gleichgültig sind ist also
überall gegen jemand in einer schädigung
oder gleich und begründet so ist es
genau genommen nicht schaden würde
von rachegefühlen suchen wir aber die
effekte des mitleids an der
schadenfreude zu werden wir finden dass
es nebeneffekt das sind die aus
ursprünglichen effekten entstehen wenn
solche durch eine bestimmte wendungen
und zwar gedanken und zwar
einbildungskraft abgeändert werden die
effekte die wiederum grüll tiere flix
hier sehen wir sind höhere stufe
geöffneten weil reflexion im spiel ist
und gedanken und die einbildungskraft
mit im spiel ist also da wird findet
eine reflexion operation auf unsere
gefühlsebene statt
und dann haben wir es mit diesen
indirekten effekten zu tun zu denen auch
das mitleid c also ist es gleichzeitig
tun weil den effekt des mitleids wo es
der vorhergehenden betrachtung des
mitgefühls zu erklären wir haben eine
lebhafte vorstellung vor allem das wird
uns in zusammenhang steht alle
menschlichen wesen aber stehen durch
ähnlichkeit mit uns in zusammen deshalb
müssen uns ihre person ihre interessen
ein effekt nennt eine freude und klein
lebhafter weise berühren und ein gefühl
hervorrufen dass den orten halt gleich
in eine lebhafte vorstellung verwandelt
sich leichten einen eindruck dieser mine
zutritt zu wird ist nur betrübnis und
komme erst recht so seien diese haben
wir immer eine anhaltende und stärkere
wirkung als irgendwelche freuden und die
müssen
ok alles sagt ganz interessant in
negativen zehner wenn es betrübt dass
kummer geht geht also wenn die andere
person ein anderes wesen er sagte nicht
nur menschen seien eben überhaupt
gewesen wenn die eben bleiben dann haben
wir starke reflexe darauf als jetzt im
positiv das ist ganz interessant also
das negative befähigt uns irgendwie
stärker anhalten da als das positive
emotionale das mag auch ein grund sein
warum wie ein kombi toren die richtig
gemerkt der letzten diskussion die
meisten behandelten emotionen wie wir
sie jetzt genannt haben irgendwie
negativ oder zumindest spannungsvoll
kommentiert sind und nicht eindeutig
sind wie eben die stimmung
es sieht als evolution können durchaus
ambivalent sein
stimmungen vielleicht auch aber stimmung
sind insgesamt ausgeglichener und
konstanter okay ganz interessant also
man könnte jetzt sagen hier dieses
abbild verhältnis dass diese reaktion
auf das original das hat etwas zu tun
mit dem was man jetzt allerdings
spiegelneuronen bezeichnet also wir
spiegeln im uns das leid den emotionalen
zustand der anderen menschen riesen ich
würde sagen ihnen nicht nur personen
sondern auch lebewesen grundsätzlich und
führen es mit aber eben auf abgeleitete
indirekte weise das heißt durch eine
form von reflexion das ist ja gerade der
flex ion bedeuteten spiegeln und
spiegelneuronen bezeichnen dass wir
gerade auch uli hat jung eigentlich
schon diese theorie der spiegel beruhen
verwickeln arbeit ganz interessant neben
betonung des negativ das ist doch
irgendwie bedeuten da in unserer
effektiven zahlen zeigen zumal ok
weiteres zitat für mich jung hinzu kommt
dass das mitleid in hohem maße von dem
her uns sondern von dem amt eines
objektes abhängt dies beweist das ist
der einbildungskraft in den stamm
kaltgestellt uns etwas vor
die einbildungskraft die lässt uns
unmittelbare eindrücke die wir bekommen
verarbeiten und neu konfigurieren aber
nicht beliebig sondern bestimmten
gesetzmäßigkeiten jedweder gegensatz
wirkt auf die einbildungskraft besonders
wenn er sich in einem zug legt findet
das mitleid hängt aber vollständig von
der eingangs kraft also die
einbildungskraft die erlaubt es einer
gewissen weise und von einem in der
direkt eindruck zu entfernen und ihn in
der vorstellung zu betrachten und es ist
klar dass es mit leid darin besteht dass
wir in der eigenen vorstellung des
leides antritt durchleiden also nicht
geld körperlich sondern eben in ein
psychisches gespiegelt sagen diese
spiegelung diese reflexivität bedeutet
nachdruck darauf hin
das ich jemals um einen effekt handelt
ich würde ihr sorge um eine emotion aber
er sagt ja auch nicht perfekt sein sagt
ja passen perfekt ist ja die deutsche
übersetzung die ich finde ein bisschen
unglücklich darüber können aber auch
noch genau das kartieren weiteres zitat
noch zur vermeidung aller zweideutigkeit
muss ich mir merken dass ich unter
einbildungskraft dann wenn ich sie dem
gedächtnis gegenstelle ganz allgemein
das vermögen verstehen dass die
schwächeren vorstellung in uns entstehen
lässt also schwächere vorstellungen sind
jetzt nicht unmittelbar und
sinneseindrücke sind die abgeleiteten
eindruck und ein dritter platz aktionen
die ihre jährige aus denen dann der für
den stehen so viel jetzt mal kurz zu dem
jung und jetzt kann man noch lange kürze
zu arthur schopenhauer der natürlich
viel später lebte aber auch von jungstar
tye erlebte in danzig damaligen ganze
und danzig ist ja in der ostsee gelegen
und insofern wie auch damals königsberg
unter einfluss gewesen von
internationalen händlern unter anderem
eben auch aus dem angelsächsischen
bereich und so kamen viele dieser
gegeben unter anderem eben von dem tup
ins damalige mit europa war das heutige
europa speziell deutschland und immanuel
kant und auto shop mauer haben diese
gegangen natürlich dankbar rezipiert als
es kurz zu schopenhauer schopenhauer ist
ganz stark an zentral für das essen
beeinflusst
er versucht jedoch diese noch tiefer zu
fassen und konzentriert sich dabei auf
der begriff des grundes und des willens
der wille sich ganz entscheidend sie
kennen alle seine schrift gilt als
million vorstellung in sicht des elends
wiederum ist besonders das mitleid
besonders ausgezeichnet warum es bei der
mit uns schon gesehen das mitleid das
motiviert uns auf ganz besondere weise
mehr als die freude und schon mal was
betrifft das mitleid ist eben der
nächsten sitzungen sehen werden kannst
theorie der achtung entgegen gesetzt es
betrifft eigentlich das von der band der
moral und hat einen metaphysischen grund
es ist also nicht nur etwas was
emotionaler natur ist zwar gewissermaßen
metaphysisches zeigt uns was die welt im
innersten zusammenhält das okay so viel
dazu jetzt lesen was er das mitleid zeit
die jetzt ausgesprochene wahrheit dass
das mitleid als den einzigen nicht
egoistisch auch die alleinige echt
moralische triebfeder sei ist seltsam
war ja fast unbegreiflicherweise paradox
ich will das mit überzeugung des jesus
dadurch zu entfremden dass ich sie als
durch die erfahrung und den aussprüche
des allgemeinen menschen geführt
bestätigt nachweis nichts empörten
tiefsten grunde unserem level wie
grausam kann jedes andere verbrechen
können wir verzeihen nur grausamkeit
nicht der grund hier von ist das
grausamkeit das gerade gegenteil dessen
kleins wir sehen also wieder reaktion
auf das negative
das motiviert besonders grenzenloses
mitleid mit allem lebenden wesen also
hier sehen wir jetzt im gegensatz zu der
region wo ist angelegt war eine
verallgemeinerung des mitleids mit
lanzen allen lebenden ps und nicht nur
mit anstiegen wesen ist der feste und
sicherste bürger für das sittliche
wohlverhalten bedarf keiner kann so ist
kasuistik ist ein regelwerk also dass
wir jetzt genau festlegen wie das midler
zu erfolgen hat
oder regeln überhaupt aufstellen wie es
kann jetzt seine idee getan hat das ist
doch schon haupt nicht notwendig das
würde uns sogar von dem
es geht um das unmittelbare grenzenlose
als metaphysische solistisch das ganze
leben
betretet ihr mitleid davon erfüllt ist
wird zuverlässig keine verletzten keine
beeinträchtigung keinem wehtun finger
mit jedem nachricht haben jedem zurzeit
jedem helfen zu viel er vermag und alle
seine handeln werden das gepräge die
richtigkeit und menschen die betrag
hingegen versuche man einmal so sagen
dieser menschen und tugendhaft aber er
kennt kein mitleid oder ist ein
ungerechter und boshafter netz jedoch
ist das eher mitleid zu widerspruch für
war okay also hier schon so ein bisschen
angeben die metaphysische dimension
das mitleid als zu tag sehen wir einmal
ganz art von einer vielleicht möglichen
metaphysischen erforschung des letzten
grund das hier ist ein kleines welchem
allein die nicht egoistischen handlung
hervorgehen können und betrachten wir
selbst ein tierischer standpunkt aus
bloß als natur anstalt zu jedem
einleuchten dass zur möglichst der
linderung der zahllosen und viel
gestalten leiden die in unser leben
ausgesetzt ist und welches keine ganze
geht wie zugleich als gegengewicht des
brennenden egoismus der alle wesen
erfüllt und auf dem großen übergeht dato
nicht wirksam und das leisten konnte als
dass das menschenherz jene wunder seine
anlagen tanzte familie das leiden das
einfach anderen mit empfunden wird
spiegel rund und aus der die stimme
hervorgeht welche je nach dem der anders
ist diese schon jedem hilft unternehmen
zu rufen okay das war es jetzt in der
zusammenfassung der heutigen sitzung wir
gehen jetzt gleich über zur diskussion
die aber auch dann erfolgen kann noch
aufführung ist